hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know with the title like rad do you
really expect many possibilities I mean
it's like hauling your movie tubular or
gnarly or whoa bishop some things you
know are doomed on arrival do you need
to know the plot No do you need to know
the characters no do you need to know
anything about this movie outside of the
title - no it absolutely sucks well let
me put it this way it doesn't help so
let us go on a most excellent adventure
this is rare so find the opening credits
of this movie you can't tell that the
focus is going to be on BMX bike racers
your bus is arrived yeah like the first
five minutes of this movie is nothing
but watching a bunch of people we don't
know doing tricks don't mind so much
except that has the moves are just a
humping the bike technique I'm serious
this is the one move they do like a
bajillion times in this movie once in a
while you get a jump here and there but
then no it's right back to the wheel
rate okay I'm sure that's difficult to
do but it looks silly and kind of
perverted move along so let's do the
credit then with the bike tricks we
finally get the beginning of our story
okay dude let's lock that sucker all
right how are we do the exact same
bullshit again
[Music]
what does the clarify this movie is
about ice game right Charlie Gorbachev
tastic growling Molly Ringwald refers LG
I can't see anything going wrong with
this scenario would be a lot better off
I killed a family in World War two
that's why I have such a harsh outlook
on reality but you don't care about that
I'm just a prop selector he rides across
the Brady Bunch lawn we see him go to
school to hang out with his friends hey
here's bad Dudley manases Katie and
higher like special that's our main
character everybody how'd it go again
Katie and I are like special weari
poetry and picked flowers at the church
by the way did think run this film for a
crowd of urine before they released it
to the public seamless yellow on the
simpsons Oh Katie isn't that crew yeah
my figures make everyone feel there oh
but I thought Katie and I were like
special you don't see a meeting ran by
the Mongoose bicycle company led by a
man they do best okay ask I'll patch you
up at the head that's right it's Oscar
from short circuit - he's in charge of
bringing a new racetrack to town and
getting some of the best-known writers
you can find a rapist
you're gonna have all the top factory
riders right here hey Katie cameras in
every corner of town showing a network
television the spirit of Cochran
excuse me who dare question the muggles
bicycling company not to put a damper on
the spirit of things
but I wonder how our kids are going to
feel when hundreds of outside young
trees take over their town and they're
not allowed to race in their own
backyard
hold me back little homie max hold me
back if I find out where you live we
will hold a qualifying race the old
lady's concern that really causes no
concern it's getting a lot of attention
around town about the race especially to
Crewe in his friends this park dude
seemed so awesome
what do you think crew I don't know it's
gonna take a radical miracle to beat
this guy a really cool as I like to call
[Music]
[Applause]
what they have no time to think about
that the fuzz is there to chase them
down because he'll if I know see officer
Krupke was very upset we never had to
love that every child all again
Giovanni
yeah so I have no clue why a balls
version of the Pringles guy is chasing
down some bikers in a Home Depot
lumberyard but nothing to give us an
excuse for cool riding
ah
oh I could have been stopping a homicide
instead of chasing YouTube I'll get you
next time you little rapscallion
Oh next week at the cruise sister punky
brewster and his mother Adrian from the
Rocky movie
no I'm serious that's Adrian from the
Rocky movies and just like in those
films her only job seems to be the
athletic cock-blocker to any rising
sports star this is a very important
race he always wanted to go to college
that's been the plan and your gut talks
to you you've listened to wash me to me
much I don't want to hear any more about
it
don't listen to her crew I've made six
movies doing the exact opposite of what
she said the next day a parade goes by
welcoming the new bikers to the town but
the bikers arms in close L tracks mystic
town we've got a good chain Joe big town
rolling in here I got a resume mr.
Kincaid well I must say the California
roll must be using imitation crab meat
what route comes across one biker that
you like Jesse's girlfriend sergeant
waters kill on the bike yeah
oh and struck me you'll see fucking more
as true tries to still impress that
Katie chick with his asphalt mountain
not too shabby huh amateur is more like
it sir are we going to the dance tonight
or what I'll be there
well great rattle pick you up at 8:00
huh what makes me think I'm going with
you okay your perky nipples they can be
pointing in my direction and you'll pick
me up how I'm not jumbo yeah sir
Katie wait did you get my we're like
special card does it go to this little
band or as the bread like to call it a
sawed-off where the Lakers put on their
finest Battlestar Galactica tire
[Music]
oh yeah I totally buy that these dances
are 100% improvised just as much as I
believe the lawsuit but gets poor act Oh
everything
it's christian hali to learn with the
act aren't you gonna show some respect
at least wait till I was done dancing
don't make me put out my skeleton
costume but go karate on your ass but
hey you think the dancing is hard to
believe
how about true in the full house jig
doing a totally unrehearsed yet somehow
completely choreographed bike damn ha
he's for the moment scenes are just so
real aren't they but then again I guess
any stunt will be easy when you do the
whole frigging thing in slow motion
[Applause]
whoever really need to look at his black
for a solid minute and I don't even want
to know what she's doing to that seat
[Music]
we know Cruz a big hit we see that big
bad Bart wants to be number one in this
year town yes sir mr. Taylor yeah what
do you got to do to get a table around
you have one for you two minutes sir
come on come on come on we get a table
as we leave have one right away sir
isn't exactly the risk expected much
more from Dairy Queen so cruel his
friend dick kick down their table we
tweet them to practice more on the ramp
and somehow off-screen the pelagic find
if you do make it a register there
they're just gonna cause you to wipe out
what are you not that's no blurry take
the mattresses out my god I never should
have moved those mattresses my bones are
jelly why did I listen to someone who
dated John Stamos y'over elitist no shit
so because breaking his back trying them
on I guess through the full house shake
hang out the other Rick crazy
no the fish to fry it would be what if
my dream came yeah I guess that scene
was so incredible we should play it
again in slow motion
movie clip the passion and maybe an hour
and a half long but he took out all the
slow-mo it only be two minutes let's
draw much drag dude a Hey why was
throwing a rock a reason to Chaser
it was a big rock
what the day is the first big race to
get into the other big race has finally
come and Duke best couldn't be more
sinisterly happy now what is the concept
behind he'll track well you see Bill we
decided that we needed our very own
super bowl so we hire the very best
expert step beyond and designed a track
that combines the different styles and
skills of BMX racers and freestylers
people just tell this guy is evil he had
to run all over it I mean could just be
running a daycare or something I know I
chosen we're going to bring this time of
the three little bit a little bit here
we go the wolf ate the Three Little Pigs
that's it no Larry found a hill like
umpteen million times and of course crew
ends up being one of the winners which
of course gives them the big race at
Hell track which doesn't please his
mother very much
don't be bowing you defied me the doors
aren't you you're willing to sacrifice
building a solid future for a bicycle
race would you try to understand the
only thing I'm good at is riding that
bike
wow that's unbelievably bad and now I
have a chance to be the best maybe the
best in the world I can take those SATs
any time maybe in six months now you
listen here I six months really yeah go
do the race do this eighties anything
you want I want you to make me a promise
six months we'll take those SATs no
matter what well yeah doesn't that kind
of going up saying is there any
indication that he wouldn't this was
really a spoiler detour I think they
just want to give the actors something
to bitch about because that's what she
does in all their other movies hey mom
I'll just go back and Burger King did
you get anything for
know what I have you but speaking of
futures Duke best trust by an offers
crew to join his team if he throws the
big ways don't understand it's a chance
of a lifetime your regret and I'm
telling it you'll love to rajole well
i'll sure you're all young room i guess
the idea behind this is duke already has
bart merchandise set up they doesn't
want to go to waste
so he'd rather have bart wind instead of
anybody else but really you'd rather
cheap and change a bunch of shirts would
it be more valuable to find an
incredible writer to make more
merchandise off of i mean in the long
run does that make more sense than just
breaking the game no well even though
crew turns him down he still raped the
gay by making it a rule that to enter
the race you need to be sponsored by a
company but wait a minute
his little sister is selling fruit
t-shirts say I bet if they sell enough
of those things they just might be able
to give enough money to count as a
sponsorship but we need the help of a
whole school in order to make that are
supposed to color the t-shirts a lot of
students try to make shirts to sell it
work as hard as they can in a black
person take your cross train
well how about that
looks like the local yokels going to
rake them up oh how about yeah now if
you will boss Craig back home Jones so
even though the shirts are selling like
mad it still looks like they're not
selling enough to qualify which puts
crew in a non rad mood what a fool I was
not to take best offers everything else
has been a joke we have to know you said
you wouldn't trade it for anything
you know nothing can compete with money
I'm glad I learned that now I thought
you were a man cuz I thought we had
something life special but now I see we
have something like not special so it
turns out that crew still needs
thousands of dollars to enter the race
but she's the whole entire town would
have to chip in and order for something
like that and I am a word here I thought
I heard it all till now
I've watched these kids grow up I've
chased every one of them why God I have
no idea but I'm wearing shades you know
any business I think crew and his
friends have done something special
real special Wow
this happened agree more special than
life special if someone doesn't see that
crew has this opportunity well I guess
we'll just all have to learn to live
with it no not with it let's give our
money to those good old boy more
constantly shaped by the law we close
your argument so the tale pulls out all
their money and even Orville Redenbacher
contributes all that he can to get crew
into the race this of course leads crew
to saying sorry that a full house chick
in probably the most laziest apology
ever
do you like to be my friend
and I'm not kidding that's it that's the
apology there is no other dialogue that
somehow actually manages to win her over
my first work fucking heartfelt speeches
on bumper stickers hey listen what would
Jesus do take me okay so the big race is
here and crew is finally ready for
action I sure hope this means watching
the same people go around the same track
about a dozen fucking times until I wish
it bulldozer would run over my nuts on a
pile of hot pokers oh no I was totally
wrong this is watching the same people
go around the same track about a dozen
fucking times until I witch a bulldozer
will run over my nuts and a pile of hot
pokers and oh by god I never thought I
would say this but play like NASCAR
oh my heart a backflip Oh
Cobra eat your heart out you see what is
this was wrestling but it's not inside a
throw that big movement there is a catch
though
Duke tells two of the writers to trick
fruit up so that part can win but get
this Bart actually wait up so they can
be more easy is Taylor stopping he wants
fruit on one on one
it's you and me Megatron it's just me
cry but of course crew ends up winning
the day I guess that whole plane fare
thing really bit you in the ass didn't
it Bart man looks like you're out of a
job huh yeah well you know this isn't
the only game in town
never what a fish think we got room on
the bad team kid I do all right yeah
what really that's how you're ending it
no interaction with your mother and
you're actually with your girlfriend
just fat
it still beans of popcorn that much
bigger impact on me don't wait at least
they're giving us something that we
haven't seen before more by size oh
please kill me you hop around like a
one-legged wallah again failure is
complete
this movie is complete ain't it it's
almost every sports cliche in the book
the characters are stale even the bike
stunts get a little old after a while
the only thing that's kind of cool are
the crashes we need to actually do look
pretty realistic as you would guess it's
not worth waiting through the rest of
this ass to get to them now can you say
about it except rad is frigging bad and
if you ever do come across a BMX biker
why don't you go ahead and give them
this movie I'm sure they need something
to make their fucking bike shop I'm
gonna sound you're Craig I remember so
you don't have to
you
[Music]
[Applause]
Haley and I are like special
yes oh my god never get sushi from jewel